Emma Stone is engaged on Wednesday
Emma's soon-to-be hubby Dave Meharry
shared this sweet pic to Instagram
revealing that he popped the question
and she said yes what a trip
yep that's the 31 year old showing off
some serious engagement bling and a
pretty epic smile Dave captioned the
shot with a simple double heart emoji
the lovebirds have been together since
2017 after they met on the set of
Saturday Night Live in 2016 where Emma
was hosting and dave is a director I
don't get it that's because it's not for
you because you have everything
everything is for you and this one thing
it's for him that was Emma starring in
the sketch wells for boys which get this
you guys dave directed how cute is that
and while the two have been pretty
private about their love they have been
spotted out and about together including
this date night in New York in April so
just who is Emma's real-life leading man
here are five fast facts you need to
know he's a three-time Emmy nominee dave
was nominated for outstanding writing
for a variety series in 2016 2017 and
2018 for his work on Saturday Night Live
he's also besties with fellow writer
comedian and SNL star Kyle Mooney why
are you stealing my look at my friends
don't you know I have like men
but these two aren't just work pals
they've been BFF since the sixth grade
Kyle and Dave also co-founded the comedy
troupe good neighbor with fellow SNL
cast member becbennett and Nick
Rutherford one two three shoot started
paper beats Rock what the hell that time
14 beats both what their YouTube videos
got millions of views and caught the
attention of Lorne Michaels and
ultimately landed them jobs on SNL in
2013 and as if his resume wasn't
impressive enough he also directed a
film in 2017 he directed the comedy
drama Briggs be bear which Kyle started
the movie premiered at the Sundance Film
Festival marking his feature directorial
debut and guess who was in attendance at
the LA premiere you guessed it Emma and
while Dave may live and work in New York
now he was born and raised in SoCal he's
from San Diego and went to USC with Kyle
for college and we have a little tip for
Dave back in 2011 Emma told ET the best
advice she can give to a man when it
comes to making a woman happy probably
being honest I think honesty really is
the best policy
there you have it keep it honest and
it'll be nothing but wedded bliss of
course you can count on ET to keep you
up to date on all things emma stone and
her upcoming I Do's so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Holly Stephens see you soon
[Music]